we have San Francisco's own Daniel Silva
[Applause]
inkmaster star Daniel Silva arrested for
murder following the death of youtuber
Corey la berry it's my birthday we might
get a little bit drunk but yeah who
knows on Monday the Los Angeles Police
Department's Valley Traffic Division
announced 27 year-old Silva's arrest the
LAPD press statement also confirmed the
car crash that killed LaBrie on his 25th
birthday
according to the statement a 20/20
McLaren 601 at a fast speed when the
driver lost control ran off the road and
collided with a stop sign and a tree
quote the driver of the McLaren exited
the vehicle and attempted to leave the
scene but was stopped by citizens who
came to render aid after the LA Fire
Department responded to the scene of the
crash both the driver and passenger were
taken to the hospital which is where the
passenger died it is alleged that Silva
was the driver and labarie is believed
to be the passenger according to arrest
records obtained by ET Silva is being
held on $200,000 bail at the LAPD Valley
Jail in Van Nuys
'la berries younger brother Jared posted
a touching tribute to Instagram Monday
writing in part quote my brother Cory
passed away last night in a car accident
with his drunk friend driving this isn't
fair
life's never going to be the same
without you
party of five actress Emily Tosta shared
a collection of photos and videos on her
Instagram and wrote in the caption quote
I don't understand this you will always
be remembered for your love and light
fellow youtubers Rebecca Black Tana mojo
and Ricky Dillon also shared tributes to
the late internet personality on Twitter
[Music]